the parents of a baby girl who grew from
a embryo frozen for more than 24 years
ago are calling her birth a miracle a
Christmas miracle they say Emma Ren
Gibson is her name she was born last
month to Tina and Benjamin in Knoxville
Tennessee researchers at the University
of Tennessee say this is the longest
frozen embryo to come to birth Adriana
Diaz is in Knoxville outside the
faith-based clinic where Tina received
the embryo Adriana this is very exciting
good morning it is indeed good morning
last March when she was 25 years old
Tina Gibson received an embryo at this
clinic that was just a year younger than
her according to the clinic's director
of the roughly 1,000 embryos that are
transferred to new parents each year
about 15% happened here 24 hours of
labor but it was worth it I'd do it
again for her 24 might be little Emma
wrens lucky number that's how many years
the embryo she grew from was frozen
before being implanted into Tina Gibson
I don't think we chose her I think she's
chosen for us Tina and her husband Ben
were struggling to have kids of their
own and her father suggested she look
into so-called
embryo adoption couples struggling to
have a child can create embryos through
in vitro fertilization sometimes embryos
that are not used are frozen and donated
to other couples like Tina and her
husband they applied at the National
embryo donation center and were accepted
we were going through the profiles it
doesn't tell how long they were frozen
so we had no idea and so the day of the
transfer dr. Kenan was like hey this is
gonna be a world record and I was like
what dr. Jeffrey Keenan performed the
procedure when the couple found out how
old these embryos were was there
hesitation did they have the option to
not go forward they would have had the
option but no there was no hesitation at
all they said wow that's great let's go
this is how Tina remembers the moment I
was like that is not neat that is no I
want a baby it's probably not gonna work
like this is crazy
Emma's birth was 24 years in the making
but her parents say it was worth the
wait
I'm 25 years old I was like if this
embryo would have been born
it was supposed to have been yeah we
could have been best friends the
Gibson's say Emma is a healthy baby one
expert we spoke to told us that the
embryo successful development is a mix
of both luck and science since methods
of freezing embryos weren't as good in
the past as they are now Anthony always
good to have a little luck on your side
I'll say I love her joy though her Yasim
about the baby but it's interesting
wonder if she would have been so excited
if she had known that it was 24 years
old you might think do you have anything
a little later than that yeah but the
baby's fine and healthy it's great it's
great our thing stayed wrinkled